hallo liebe zuschauer von easy kämen wir
sind wieder oder immer noch in windhoek
die hauptstadt von namibia wie ihr wisst
arbeiten wir mit dem goethe institut
zusammen um schülern hier in windhoek zu
helfen deutsch zu lernen und diese fünf
jungen damen sprechen ausgezeichnet
deutsch
denn bei mir sind heute ich bin merlini
hallo ich bin nur die heiße wetter und
ich heiße vanessa und die fünf jungen
damen werden heute mal in namibia hier
menschen auf der straße fragen und zwar
auf deutsch denn tatsächlich gibt es
hier einige deutschen muttersprache und
vor allem auch viele deutsche touristen
das werdet ihr gleich sehen und sie
waren heute wissen was mögen die
menschen an namibia
was haben sie in namibia gesehen es geht
also um das land und die leute
viel spaß beim zuschauen
was lieben sie an namibia ich liebe an
in namibia die unterschiedlichen
landschaften die menschen die sehr
freundlich sind und ich bin zum ersten
mal in namibia und komme bestimmt
irgendwann wieder mal hierher
wir fielen sie die namibische menschen
sehr nett und sehr höflich und sehr
zuvorkommend will sind
ich bin brigitte komme aus deutschland
haben sie einen lieblingsort in namibia
ja ich war meinen schwiegersohn ist weil
es einfach schön heißt in windhuk auf
der farm zu sein
hallo guten morgen guten morgen woher
kommen sie
wir kommen aus münchen bayerisches teil
von deutschland ganz schönes land groß
viel größer als der holland wo ich
vorher kommen und sie ja weit und weite
flächen und schöne tiere und ich liebe
es unglaublich ja wohl die landschaft
die berge die wüste die tiere die lodge
ist alles wunderbar was mögen sie einen
berg am wetter wegen wegen der kultur
unterschiedliche leute hier keine ahnung
ist halt
ein schönes land solche namibia ist ein
tolles weites land mit sehr vielen
netten menschen namibia sehr schöne
steine die geologie sehr interessant und
und auch die leute sie sind meistens
sehr am awo café ist das
deutschfreundlich die meisten abidi
sprechen auch afrikanischen das ist er
ähnliche mit allen nicht ist einfach
woher kommen sie aus deutschland ich
komme auch aus deutschland was lieben
sie ein namibier die menschen sehr
freundlich zu uns wir sind auch nicht
ja wir sind aus deutschland leben
gekommen nicht aus namibia und jeder
nimmt uns sehr nett auf hier ja und sie
ja ich mache das auch sehr gerne auch
die natur und die ladentische
richtig schön weil es einfach so anders
ist als in deutschland wo fahren sie hin
werden wir am donnerstag starten wie
gesagt meine frau kommt nach erst
lauterberg dann zwei tage enttäuscht an
skeletten b und zwei tages war kuppen
und dann wieder zurück nach windhoek und
dann geht der flieger nach deutschland
wir sind hier 4000 kilometer gefahren in
der media ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
mir hat am besten
der bereich war gut gefallen diese tolle
berg diese städte dieser wandel sehr
schön
es war sehr schön ich mag das gerne
diese einsamkeit mit die die mit ihr
abgestorbene bäume das war sehr schön
ein ort lieblingsort noch nicht gefunden
noch nicht gefunden und sie als überall
schön beeindruckt im bereich von zusatz
von der wüste warum er weiß bei uns so
was nicht gibt ja eine ganz ganz andere
landschaft naja ich denke die wüste in
sofia
warum weil es dort sehr warm es im
gegensatz zu deutschland und die dünnen
einfach unbeschreiblich schön aussehen
zum sonnenaufgang untergang die natur
die menschen das ganze land und die
fläche also schönes land war es peking
die deutsch-deutsche mein erster
muttersprache in deutschland
aufgewachsen und studiert auch wenn
alles daher schwach dortmund ist auch
sehr schön das ist erstaunlich man glatt
mann ist in deutschland alle leute
sprechen doch oder viele leute sprechen
noch deutsch haben du ein lieblingsort
genommen ja ich mag mehr die küste warum
warum weil familien an die priester die
älteste wüste in der welt ist guten
morgen
wie findet sie namibia ist ein schönes
land gar nichts sagen und es freut auch
uns leute unsere land zu zeigen und dann
über unsere sicher zu erzählen so
namibia finde ich immer aus einer
schönes land wunderschönes land in
welchen tiere haben sieg
wir haben ganz viele tiere gesehen aber
am spannendsten war dass wir mit dem
eigenen wagen durch ethischer gefahren
sind und plötzlich sah ich neben uns
drei meter entfernung einen richtig
alten elefantenbullen und da haben wir
erst mal lange gehalten und haben ihn
fotografiert aber dann habe auch ein
bisschen respekt bekommen und sind dann
langsam weiter gefahren vorhaben
ich habe deutsch gelernt in der schule
das so mahnte lutherschule gewissen
kirche schule 50 prozent von unsere
touristen sind deutsche kommen aus
deutschland
und die wollen immer mit ein und andere
redner manchmal wenn diese leute nicht
endlich und ist ganz wichtig dass du
dann mit er dann in ihre eigene
muttersprache und dann ja und ja das ist
wohin aber wir waren sie wir sind
angefangen in windhoek dann rehoboth cat
mannshoch und dann weiter in den süden
runter bis zu fisch wie asthma
fischküche übergehen fish river canyon
wir sind mit dem zug gefahren von
kapstadt bis nach windhuk
und es war eine sehr schöne reise und
dann ging es weiter nach luft park
wieder hoch dann betritt und von
lüttwitz ging's weiter sag' mal schnell
22.02 bund und dann ging es wieder
weiter hoch
in dem nationalpark haben sie einen
lieblingsort in namibia
wenn du gefällt mir ganz gut ist meine
meinen heimatort hier genau da will ich
ganz gerne richtig
wir sind gestern angekommen von daher
gesehen können wir nur windows 7 das
erste ich liebe springbock ich war
vorgestern schauspielhaus und habe
endlich wieder springbock gegessen
liebes gering sagt ja ihr lieben das war
sie die episode führt diese woche
gemeinsam mit dem goethe institut ihre
namibia diesmal wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen und wir hoffen natürlich ihr
habt jetzt viele gute gründe bekommen
selber mal nach namibia zu fahren ihr
seht die leute die hier im von lieben
dieses land und genauso ist es bei uns
wir fahren seit vielen jahren immer
wieder nach namibia und ja für uns ist
namibia sogar so eine art zweite heimat
geworden
wenn ihr lust habt kommt doch mal vorbei
und wenn ihr lust habt unser projekt zu
unterstützen um mehr easy german zu
produzieren
dann freuen wir uns wahnsinnig über
euren support bei patchen das könnt ihr
hier unten machen und wenn ihr mehr easy
german sehen wollt dann abonniert
unbedingt unseren kanal bei youtube das
geht hier um danke fürs zuschauen bis
zur nächsten woche